followed threatened and beaten for their
watches
[Music]
on the streets of Britain watch thefts
are on the rise
there's a break there break there and a
break there Nick Triggs and his wife
were attacked at random and robbed in
West London last January a black BMW X5
screeches to a hawk beside me
the door opens
a guy gets out and and smashes me on the
left cheekbone there's a another person
showing me a 15-inch machete I think is
he going to kill me
another one I think the first guy shouts
give me your watch
after a police helicopter chase through
Central London a gang of six men were
eventually caught and convicted over a
rampage of violent robberies
Nick was targeted near South Kensington
one of the wealthiest parts of London
these are the sorts of areas The Gangs
operate in they'll wait outside high-end
restaurants or bars even what shops and
they also use social media to find their
victims if you post a picture of your
expensive watch say with your live
location or they know where to find you
in many areas it's actually over taken
drugs as the crime of choice for some
criminal gangs drugs are obviously very
dangerous to carry to hold to transport
whereas what is are very simple and very
rarely questioned as an example you
can't get on a plane with a kilo of
cocaine but you can get on a plane with
a million pounds for stolen watches and
I very much doubt that anyone will even
bat an eyelid the criminal gangs know
this they use that to their advantage
since 2015 the number of watches stolen
in England and Wales has nearly doubled
more than 11
000 were stolen last year over half here
in London so here we have a Rolex
Daytona with a mother of pearl dial with
diamond indexes since the pandemic
there's been a boom in the value of
second-hand watches that's what's
driving the criminals not a lot of
watches were produced so the value
increased massively this would have been
around a hundred thousand pounds just
before lockdown today it's around 185
000. Danny's become so worried he's now
offering a free chauffeur service to get
customers home safely these gangs have
clearly found an easy way to make a lot
of money with little care of how their
brutal violence scars their victims
Rachel Venable's Sky News